Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I’m going to explain an episode from
an American anthology “American Horror Story”
called “Monsters Among Us”.
Spoilers ahead.
Watch out and take care
The episode begins with a girl named Dot Tattler
telling us about the day, when the world as
she had known ended while walking into what
seems like a circus fair.
It was Saturday, the third of September, 1952.
She says the shadows that had sheltered her
were banished by the blinding lights of scrutiny.
She knew she was entering the gates of hell
but like the inescapable pull of gravity,
there was nothing she could do about it.
The movie then cuts to a milk man arriving
at Eudora Tattler’s country farmhouse in
Jupiter, Florida.
He notices that Mrs. Tattler still hasn’t
picked up her delivery from the other day.
Worried, he ventures into her home to inspect.
To his horror, he finds Mrs. Tattler’s brutally
murdered dead body lying next to the dining
table.
He freaks out but decides to further investigate.
He grabs a dough roller from the kitchen and
heads upstairs.
He follows a strange noise coming from inside
a closet but only to freak out even more.
The episode then cuts to an injured woman
being wheeled into an operating room.
A nurse appears from the room with a look
of disgust in her face from what she witnesses
and vomits in the hall.
The doctor examines the woman through an x-ray
machine and reveals that the injured woman
has one bladder, three kidneys, four lungs,
two hearts with a shared circulatory system.
Later, a nurse reads a news article about
the incident.
It says a wounded "monstrous creature", possibly
a blood relative of Mrs. Tattler, was found
in her home.
who was thought to have lived alone.
A candy stripper named Penny speculates that
the “monster” was Mrs. Tatler’s child
who she kept hidden from the world.
A woman named Elsa Mars arrives and makes
small talk with Penny before asking her about
the “extraordinary creature” that’s
rumoured to have been brought in the hospital.
Penny refuses to give her information about
the patient but Elsa appeals to Penny’s
young inner rebel and hands her a business
card that says Fraulein Elsa's Cabinet of
Curiosities, asking her to visit.
Later, Elsa dresses up in Penny’s outfit
and makes her way into the Secure wing where
the patient has been kept.
She peeks through the curtains to find a woman
with two heads sleeping on the bed.
They are Dot and Bette Tattler, Mrs. Tattler’s
daughters.
Elsa removes the curtains and wakes them up,
complimenting their beauty.
She hands the sisters a balloon and reveals
that she dropped by their home to get them
a comfortable dress and because she is nosy.
It turns out that the two sisters can communicate
telepathically.
Dot has a serious demeanor and loves quiet
while Bette is more bubbly and likes watching
movies.
Elsa fails to charm Dot, who sees through
her and is wary of her intentions but manages
to smooth talk Bette, comparing her to Jean
Arthur.
She asks the girls about their sexlife and
boyfriends which makes Bette giggle while
Dot scoffs in disgust.
Elsa then leaves the sisters alone but not
before promising to return.
The scene then cuts to a couple, Troy Miller
and Bonnie Lipton making out by the lake Okeechobee.
Suddenly, Troy runs to his car to fetch something.
As Bonnie waits for her lover to come back,
someone is seen coming out of the bush and
walking towards her.
The girl finally notices the person and it
is revealed to be a clown.
It has a creepy grinning mask on the lower
half of his face.
Bonnie is scared of him at first but the clown
genuflects and gives her fake flowers, making
her feel more secure and comfortable.
The clown then pulls out bowling pins from
his crown bag as Troy returns.
Bonnie again gets nervous when she learns
that Troy didn’t hire him.
The clown again pretends to genuflects and
knocks the couple out with the bowling pin.
When Bonnie gains consciousness, she finds
the clown stabbing Troy to death with a pair
of scissors.
Frightened, she attempts to run but the clown
catches up to her.
At a diner, Elsa is cutting newspaper clippings
for her scrapbook about movies while other
patrons are reading about the horrific murder
at the Tattler house.
Elsa notices a guy named Jimmy Darling, who
is wearing leather mittens, flirting with
a waitress on the other side of the diner,
which for some reason enrages her.
She confronts him and calls him out for flirting
with girls while she worked her ass off to
find this new place that they can call home.
Somewhere they can expand their show and build
an audience.
Jimmy retorts that he overheard their landlord
asking her to leave and tells her she is living
in delusion.
In a flashback sequence, Elsa is seen hanging
laundry while holding a two feet tall grown
woman named Ma Petite when her landlord Mr.
Haddonfield approaches and tells her that
he wants her to vacate his land.
He wants to lease his land to someone else
who is willing to pay in advance and in cash.
He tells her that even though she signed a
lease for a year, she hasn’t had any customers
for her show in two months.
Moreover, Mr. Haddonfield’s wife doesn’t
like having the “freaks” staying in the
field.
Elsa retorts that her monsters wouldn’t
hurt a fly and shows her landlord her silk
Belgian lingerie.
She hands him her lingerie and invites her
into her room for “schnapps”.
Back to the present, Elsa tells Jimmy to mind
his business when he wonders outloud how she
managed to convince the landlord to let them
stay for another month.
She then tauntingly asks him what the waitress
he was flirting with would think of his “deformity”.
Jimmy brushes her comment aside and tells
her that it is over, which only enrages Elsa
and she tells him that things are going to
change and she has a plan.
The movie then cuts to a suburban home where
a group of housewives have gathered for a
kitty party where they complain to each other
about their bad sex lives.
A woman then appears from the back room, grinning,
strutting and smiling ear to ear as if someone
just laid some really good pipe on her.
The host then approaches the shy wife among
the group and raves to her about a “roadside
attraction”.
The shy wife then goes to the back bedroom
where Jimmy is waiting for her with his mittens
off.
It turns out Jimmy’s hands are deformed.
The woman lays on the bed and lifts her dress
up and Jimmy proceeds to do his magic.
Back at the hospital, Elsa asks the girls
about the night their mother was murdered.
Dot claims that it was a robbery gone bad.
She says the robber got enraged when he realised
that they had nothing to steal and killed
their mother in anger before attacking them.
Bette adds that the man wore a fedora and
reeked of Aqua Velva.
However, as Bette continues, Elsa recognizes
the plot from a hollywood movie called “Gaslight”.
Elsa then reveals that she knows Mrs. Tattler
died two days ago before the sisters were
found with fresh wounds.
She sees through their Bullshit and tells
them to get their story straight before the
police approaches them.
Meanwhile, the creepy clown continues to go
on a crime spree.
He brutally murders a couple, Jeffrey and
Mildred Bachman, in their home and abducts
their 8 year old son Corey.
The series of murders and kidnappings in a
span of one month in an otherwise peaceful
town leads the police to believe that the
same maniac killed the Bachmans, Mrs Tattler,
Troy Miller and kidnapped Corey and Bonnie.
The clown has held Corey and Bonnie captive
in a dilapidated trailer in what seems like
the middle of a jungle.
Seeing the boy so frightened, the man tries
to get the boy to smile but only ends up scaring
him even more.
Frustrated, the clown then starts throwing
things at the cage.
Afraid of getting arrested, the Tattler sisters
run from the hospital but Elsa catches them
red handed at home preparing to flee.
She accuses them of killing their mother.
She speculates that Bette must have killed
Mrs. Tattler in a fit of rage when she won’t
take them to the movies or let them go out.
Dot admits and claims Bette didn’t know
what she was doing, causing Elsa to speculate
that Dot stabbed Bette to make it seem like
they were also victimised by their mother’s
killer.
Bette comes straight to the point and asks
what Elsa wants from them.
Elsa finally reveals her true intentions and
takes the sisters to her home.
She plans to use them as the star attractions
of her freak show that features abnormally
developed people.
It is September 3.
Bette journals in her diary about finally
being free.
She is mesmerized by the silk, glamour and
lights of the circus.
Meanwhile, Dot dreads the future and longs
for the quiet of the farm.
Elsa’s freaks include Jimmy’s mother Ethel,
the bearded woman; Meep the geek; Pepper and
others.
Jimmy grows worried about the police looking
for the Tattler sisters but Elsa tells him
that she plans to be their alibi.
On Elsa’s orders Jimmy puts up a poster
of their show highlighting their star attractions:
The Siamese sisters.
A car full of young hooligans pass by and
harass Jimmy and other few freaks for being
different, reminding Jimmy how the world treats
them differently because of their condition.
Later that night, a disheveled Penny storms
into the dinning room and confronts Elsa for
drugging her.
However, Elsa laughs her off and reminds her
that she willingly came with them.
She shows Penny a footage of a happy Penny,
high as a kite, making out and performing
sexual acts with Jimmy and the others freaks.
Stunned and horrified, Penny proceeds to leave,
threatening to tell the world about the depravity
of the freaks but Elsa stops her and tells
her that the real monsters are outside this
tent in the suburbs.
The bored, bitter, stifled, soul less housewives
who dream of strange erotic pleasures behind
closed doors.
Meanwhile, Elsa's monsters who others call
“depraved” are beautiful heroes who offer
their oddity, laugh, and fright to the people
in need of entertainment unabashedly.
They lead the life they chose unlike others.
The next day, Jimmy hands his mom the money
he made entertaining housewives and tells
her that he wants to leave the show to live
a normal life.
But Ethel shuts him down and tells him this
is the “normal” for them.
Later, Jimmy notices a detective inside Dot
and Bette’s tent proceeding to arrest them
on suspicion of murdering their mother.
Jimmy defends them, saying they wouldn’t
hurt a fly but the detective calls the twins
depraved monsters who could do anything.
Fed up with being ridiculed and disrespected
for being different, Jimmy kills the detective
in a fit of rage.
For the first time Dot feels a sense of community
with the freaks and thanks Jimmy for saving
them.
That night, a snooty and entitled guy named
Dandy Mott and his mother Gloria sit in the
audience waiting for the show to start.
It is revealed Goria bought the entire show
just for her son.
Soon, Ethel opens the show and introduces
the man with hands for arms, Pepper, Ma Petite
and the Siamese sisters.
Next, Elsa takes the stage and belts out a
David Bowie number with the freaks performing
behind her.
Dandy develops a liking for Dot and Bette
and after the performance, Gloria tells Elsa
she wants to buy the twins for her son, revealing
she is willing to go as high as $15,000.
However, Dot and Bette turn down the offer
saying the freaks show is their home.
Upset, Gloria makes fun of Elsa calling her
attempt at singing “pathetic” and “the
most freakish thing of all tonight” before
storming out.
Afterwards, Jimmy leads a procession of the
freaks to bury the detective in the woods.
He delivers a passionate speech, calling out
how badly the world treats them.
He says if the world wants to call them monsters
without even knowing them, then they will
act like monsters.
He vows that if anyone tries to mess with
them from now on, they will end up like the
detective.
The freaks then converge near the detective
and hack him to bits as the clown watches
it transpire from a distance.
Later, when Elsa skips dinner, Ethel brings
food to her tent.
It seems Gloria’s words seem to have taken
a toll on Elsa’s mind.
When Ethel thanks Elsa for saving them by
bringing the twin sisters, Elsa confesses
that she didn’t bring the twins to save
the show, she brought them to save herself.
Elsa has always wanted to become a star but
now she wonders if it’s too late for her.
Taking Elsa’s opium pipe away, Ethel assures
her that she is gifted and meant to become
a household name.
After Ethel leaves, Elsa puts on some music
and takes off her pantyhose, revealing her
artificial legs.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.